nouvelle manifestation nationale des
infirmières à l'appel de leur
coordination qu'elle s'ajoute celle des
aides-soignants des agents de service et
des personnels de santé toutes
catégories confondues la mobilisation
est intacte dit les infirmières nous ne
retourneront pas au travail si nous
n'obtenons pas des garanties sur nos
revendications
la manifestation débuté ce matin à 10
heures la coordination comptait
rassembler 100 mille personnes pari tenu
ou déception réponse avec ecc mettait
bien avoir ce matin avec la première
manifestation des infirmières le 29
septembre
aujourd'hui certes c'est bien la
coordination des infirmières qui ouvrent
le cortège
mais le gros de la troupe des
manifestants est constitué de personnels
hospitaliers autres infirmiers aides
soignants agents administratifs
ils ont organisé eux aussi en
coordination ou bien sont venus à
l'appel de la cgt qui accompagne la
marche
la cohabitation syndicat coordination
n'est pas toujours facile henri krasucki
qui a voulu marcher en tête du cortège
s'est vu construite par la coordination
toujours aussi déterminé
nous n'avons rien pratiquement rien eu
rien obtenu depuis depuis quinze jours
trois semaines que le mouvement a été
suspendu et nous sommes bien décidés à
nous battre encore plus dur beaucoup
plus dur je crois sur les choses
n'avancent pas mais c'est justement pour
ça qu'il faut pas s'arrêter là
coordination des infirmières sera reçue
tout à l'heure à 14h par claude evin au
ministère de la santé